en el vídeo pasado dibuje este cuadro
para observar mejor las distintas
combinaciones de alelos que puede
obtener de mama o del papá a este tipo
de cuadros se les llama cuadros de bonet
déjeme ponerlo aquí
y resulta y puede ser este dato curioso
el vídeo que estuve buscando que
significaba poner y entonces me di
cuenta que cuando tú vas al mercado y
ves estás canastillas cuadriculadas
justo la voy a poner aquí ésta es una
canastilla de las que te hablo en las
cuales se ponen todas las fresas y las
moras son pequeñas caras astillas muy
parecidas a ésta seguramente has visto
alguna y aquí ponen todas las frutas
parecidas a las fresas ya las moras pero
éstas son como rendijas son una pequeña
cuadrícula o canastillas cuadricular es
en la cual ponemos justo aquí algunas
frutas se dejan en dibujar algunas
ponemos algunas fresas aquí hay algunas
fresas luego también algunas moras
déjame poner con este color
algunas moras también aquí hay algunas
moras o uvas podemos poner en estas
tranquilas y déjame poner otra empresa
por aquí por aquí voy a poner otra fresa
y bueno justo a estas canastillas en
algunos países se les conoce con el
nombre de punta
creo que en la tierra es uno de esos
países pero bueno buscando un poco más
resulta que el nombre de cuadros de
punnett no se debe a estas caras tías y
de hecho tiene un poco de lógica con
estas canastillas pero no reciben este
nombre debido a su creador el genetista
británico reginal uned y estos cuatros
de pune no son solamente útiles cuando
hablamos de la cruza de dos híbridos
como en este caso y estudiamos sólo una
característica el cuadro que dibujamos
es un ejemplo de esto recuerda que
hicimos una cruza de dos híbridos para
una sola característica a este tipo de
cruzadas también se desconoce como mono
híbridos los cuadros también son útiles
para ver combinaciones de varias
características cuando dos organismos
reproductivos se producen y también
sirven situaciones donde una cosa domina
la otra y es por eso que en este vídeo
vamos a trabajar varias opciones
parecidas para que te familiarices con
este concepto y para eso voy a bajar un
poco la pantalla y voy a seguir con la
analogía de los ojos azules y los ojos
cafés ahora digamos que
a tu mamá tiene ojos cafés así que va a
tener el homo cigoto dominante y ve en
mayúscula b mayúscula y tu papá vamos a
decir que tu papá es el del cigoto
etc por lo tanto va a tener un alelo en
mayúscula y un alelo en minúscula estás
de acuerdo y ahora queremos saber los
distintos genotipos que sus hijos pueden
tener y para ver esto vamos a hacer de
nuevo un cuadro de monet y por ello voy
a hacer aquí mi cuadrícula déjame
dibujar una pequeña cuadrícula
por aquí voy a poner los otros genes y
bueno aquí voy a tener las posibles
combinaciones justo por aquí justo por
aquí y aquí arriba del cuadro voy a
poner los alelos que puede dar el padre
el padre si te das cuenta puede dar un
alelo del color de ojos cafés y un alelo
del color de ojos azules mientras que la
mamá puede dar dos alelos café es éste y
éste deja de escribir que aquí me estoy
fijando en el papá en el papá mientras
que aquí me voy a fijar en la
lo voy a poner así aquí estoy hablando
de mamá ahora bien en este caso de aquí
date cuenta que la mamá va a contribuir
con un alelo dominante de mayúscula para
los ojos cafés y el papá también por lo
tanto vamos a tener un nuevo cigoto
dominante mientras que aquí la mama va a
heredar este alelo de los ojos cafés
mientras que el papá verdad este alelo
de los ojos azules aquí tenemos un
heterocigotos acá abajo date cuenta que
vamos a tener lo mismo que acá arriba la
mama va a donar un alelo de los ojos
cafés y el papá también y esto es porque
la mamá solo puede donar un alelo para
los ojos cafés un alelo dominante y
ahora darte cuenta que en este otro caso
la mama va a donar de nuevo el alelo
dominante pero el papá va a donar el
alelo recesivo este de aquí y vamos a
tener un hetero cigoto recuerda que la
mama tiene dos cromosomas homólogos y
cada uno de ellos tiene el mismo al dedo
que hacen
entonces puedes obtener el otro
cromosoma de la mama y tener la misma
combinación de acá arriba ahora
preguntémonos por lo siguiente cuál es
la probabilidad de tener un hijo con
ojos azules suponiendo que el color azul
es recesivo recuerda una cosa es hablar
del fenotipo que en este caso es tener
un hijo con los ojos azules y otra cosa
es hablar de las combinaciones de los
genotipos que son estas que tenemos aquí
bueno para tener los ojos azules los
ojos
azules que necesitamos necesitamos tener
el homo cigoto recesivo be minúscula de
minúsculas estás de acuerdo y entonces
pues la probabilidad de tener esto bueno
como puedes ver aquí no hay ninguno que
tenga esta combinación entonces es 0% 0
por ciento de probabilidad de tener un
hijo con ojos azules y si ahora te
pregunto cuál es la probabilidad de
tener un hijo que sea homo cigoto
dominante
sin voto dominante
y nantes bueno pues recuerda que un
motivo terminante es la forma de
mayúscula be mayúscula y ahora no
estamos hablando del fenotipo en esta
ocasión estamos hablando del genotipo y
si te das cuenta aquí tengo uno de ellos
y aquí tengo otro de ellos y por lo
tanto tengo dos combinaciones de cuatro
dos combinaciones de cuatro lo cual me
da un 50% de probabilidad y bueno
podemos hacer estos cuadros de pune
incluso cuando una de estas
características no necesariamente domina
sobre la otra y para eso vamos a ver un
ejemplo déjame bajar la pantalla porque
ahora vamos a ver el siguiente ejemplo
sobre dominancia incompleta es más
déjenme meterlo aquí voy a fijarme en la
dominancia
lancia incompleta
con
a qué me refiero con dominancia
incompleta bueno cuando tenemos
características que no necesariamente
una domina sobre la otra digamos que
tenemos dos colores para un tipo de flor
y vamos a imaginar que solamente puede
haber dos tipos de flores las flores
rojas rojas y las flores blancas me
gustan las flores blancas
blancas así que imagínate esta situación
donde uno de los padres o bueno esta
planta podría ser padre o madre y
realmente esto no aplica para las
plantas
hablamos de flores femeninas y
masculinas incluso esta misma planta
pero bueno vamos a pensar que una de las
que se reproducen tiene el genotipo r d
mayúscula en mayúscula y voy a pensar
que el otro tiene el mismo genotipo r&b
en mayúscula y voy a hacer aquí en mi
cuadro de pune bueno pues hagamos el
cuadro lo voy a hacer por aquí por aquí
por aquí y por aquí lo que quiero
fijarme o lo que yo pensar es en cuáles
son las diferentes combinaciones
posibles y bueno volvamos a nuestro
cuadro de poulet y vamos a hacer esto la
planta puede dar ambos sale los rojos en
este caso tengo un alelo rojo después de
la planta padre y un alelo rojo de la
planta madre mostró ponerlo aquí voy a
tener un alelo rojo
aquí de la planta madre y un alelo
blanco de la planta padre esta vez es
justo esta que tengo aquí y esta ere
viene de aquí ahora puedo también tener
que el padre mere de un alelo rojo y la
madre un alelo blanco esta vez es esta
vez de aquí o bueno puede ser también
que tenga blanco blanco estás de acuerdo
pero recuerda que ahora estamos hablando
de dominancia incompleta si yo me
pregunto qué significa esto bueno eso va
a significar que cuando ves los
fenotipos ves una mezcla de dos
genotipos una mezcla y esta palabra es
muy importante porque qué significa
bueno que si yo tuviera la dominancia
completa y si el rojo fuera el dominante
entonces todos estos serían dominantes
estás de acuerdo uno dos tres eso ya lo
vimos en este caso si tuviéramos una
dominancia completa entonces tendríamos
tres flores rojas y una flor
solamente un cuarto de probabilidad de
tener flores blancas pero en el caso de
dominancia incompleta el genotipo
heterocigotos que tenemos de muestra
esté r&b va a ser una mezcla de ambos
así que imagínate que esto nos va a dar
como resultado una flor rosa rosa
imagínate esto es tan impresionante
porque ahora podemos tener flores rosas
ya eso nos referimos con una mezcla es
una combinación de ambos alelos entonces
si estas dos plantas se van a reproducir
y las características del color de las
flores se manifiestan de acuerdo a la
dominancia incompleta entonces te puedo
preguntar cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener una flor rosa y ahora si tiene
sentido tener una flor rosa porque me
estoy fijando en las diferentes
combinaciones y habló de este genotipo
como ver un fenotipo de flor rosa
entonces cuál es la probabilidad bueno
pues tengo uno de los casos dos de los
casos entonces van a ser dos de 1 2 3 4
de 4 casos es decir un 50%
tengo un 50% de probabilidad de tener
flores rosas y podemos seguir haciendo
esto para muchas generaciones y
preguntarnos qué pasa en la segunda en
la tercera en la cuarta generación pero
también podemos tener una situación
donde haya múltiples alelos distintos y
pueden usar un ejemplo mucho más real
quiero hablar ahora de el tipo de sangre
así que usar el tipo de sangre como
ejemplo imagínate que en esta ocasión
tengo tres alelos potenciales el alelo
tipo de sangre ambos tipos de sangre am
el tipo de sangre be y el tipo de sangre
lo que sucede en este ejemplo es que hay
genes dominantes y recesivos y para ver
esto vamos a hacer un cuadro de puzzle
entonces digamos que uno de mis padres
es ave a ver dicho de otra manera
significa que uno de sus cromosomas
homólogos tiene el alelo
y el otro cromosoma tiene el alelo ven
eso es lo que significa ser a b en este
caso vamos a decir que el fenotipo es el
genotipo y esos dos son quienes q
dominantes ambos expresan no se mezclan
ambos se expresan y esto sucede con el
tipo de sangre
avn así que déjenme ponerlo este es el
tipo de sangre tipo de sangre ave ave y
ahora imagínate que el otro padre tiene
un tipo de sangre
es decir su fenotipo 'san de tipo am
pero bueno espero no confundirte su
genotipo va a ser
y es decir tiene una lengua y otro alelo
y esto es algo muy interesante acerca
del tipo de sangre es una mezcla entre
genes recesivos y ccoo dominantes el gen
o este de aquí es un gen recesivo
vivo mientras que ave estos son
dominantes q de mí
antes que quiere decir eso que cuando
tenemos a v con una y éstos dominan por
lo tanto tendremos un tipo de sangre
joven y si ave están juntos entonces
tenemos un tipo de sangre a b ambos
dominan entonces nos fijamos en el
cuadro de paulette como me va a quedar a
déjame dibujarlo por aquí tengo cuatro
posibilidades dejarme hacerlo así voy a
poner aquí para que no se confundan los
padres y ahora sí vamos a fijarnos
primero en este cuadro de aquí en este
cuadro de aquí tu padre te va a donar
este alelo a mientras que tu madre te va
a donar este alelo a y en este caso
bueno claramente vamos a tener un tipo
de sangre
y si tenemos aquí este caso bueno puesto
un padre va a andar esta ley lo ven y tu
madre va a donar ésta le loa en este
caso tenemos un tipo de sangre a ver
porque ambos son como dominantes y ahora
qué va a pasar aquí en este caso tu
padre va a donar una
y tu madre va a donar un alelo
y en este caso vas a tener un tipo de
sangre am porque a domina al lado estás
de acuerdo
la o es recesiva y en este caso de camps
bueno pues tu padre te va a dar este
alelo b ojo es éste le lo ve éste se lo
ve en este lo ve recuerda que está
pasando justo por aquí mientras que tu
madre te va a dar este lelo y en este
caso vas a tener un tipo de sangre ve
porque recuerda que el pp también domina
a la y entonces sí digo cuál es la
probabilidad de tener sangre tipo a
dejarlo aquí cuál es la probabilidad de
tener sangre tipo a bueno pues en este
caso bueno pues vamos a fijarnos lo
siguiente está en definitiva es un tipo
de sangre estás de acuerdo
tenemos dos alelos y por lo tanto
tenemos un tipo de sangre
pero también este caso de kim este caso
de aquí también es un tipo de sangre
porque sabemos que es recesivo entonces
éste también da un tipo de sangre a a
estos dos dan un tipo tipo de sangre a
tipo a entonces si veo que tengo
solamente dos posibilidades tengo un 50%
de probabilidad de tener un tipo de
sangre a dos de cuatro y tú pueden ser
todas las combinaciones posibles y te
puedes preguntar
cómo puedes tener un tipo de sangre no
sé en o y para esto sus dos padres
necesitan tener al menos una o para ver
esto
imagínate que en este cuadro en lugar de
esta vez se me ocurre a pongo una y
entonces aquí tendría un ojo y tendrías
tipo de sangre o en fin espero que esto
te dé una idea de cómo puede ser útil un
cuadro de pep uned y también puede ser
útil cuando hablamos de más
características y para eso déjame bajar
un poco en la pantalla porque voy a
trabajar un poco con el ejemplo anterior
el ejemplo donde hablamos del
color de ojos así que hablemos de nuevo
de el color de ojos y recuerda que la de
minúscula significaba o hablábamos de
ojos azules recuerdas
azules y también hablábamos la mayúscula
ya ve en mayúscula quedan ojos color
café
cafés y bueno esta era una
característica dominante dominante
ahora estoy siendo todo esto porque
ahora vamos a tener otra característica
se me ocurre pensar en el tamaño de los
dientes como introduje anteriormente
entonces este minúscula va a ser el
alelo que me habla de los dientes
pequeños dientes pequeños
qué años y bueno también voy a pensar en
t mayúscula en mayúscula como el alelo
de los dientes grandes de
tres grandes grandes donde estoy seguro
que yo quería en los dientes grandes
pero bueno ahora imagínate lo siguiente
un individuo que tiene por ejemplo a
heterocigotos para los ojos cafés déjame
ponerlo así va a ser ve en mayúsculas y
minúsculas porque es un heterocigotos
heterocigotos con ojos cafés y además
que va a ser homo cigoto dominante para
los dientes grandes como cigoto
dominante para los dientes grandes y
entonces este va a ser mi genotipo bebé
de este tipo sería justo en esto déjeme
notarlo por aquí este va a ser mi
individuo y bueno este individuo me está
diciendo en primera parte por aquí que
tiene dientes grandes dientes grandes
grandes y bueno sabemos que el fenotipo
de esta parte que tengo aquí de esta
parte que tengo aquí es expresar ojos
cafés
y bueno si suponemos que los genes que
codifican para el tamaño de dientes o
para el color de ojos están en distintos
cromosomas y este supuesto es clave para
decir que los genes se segregan
independientemente esto es muy
importante que se segregan
independientemente lo voy a poner aquí
creación independiente
de p
diente y esto lo voy a poner de esta
manera si estuviéramos viendo los
cromosomas y digamos que por aquí tengo
a uno de los pares homólogos y por aquí
tengo a otro de ellos voy a suponer que
este es un primer paro homólogo y bueno
claro tenemos 23 pero no sé supongamos
para hacerlo más fácil y ejemplificar
esto que por aquí tengo a mi segundo par
homólogo dejarlo por aquí son homólogos
así que voy a poner que este es mi
segundo par homólogo si el gen de color
de ojos está justo por aquí
imagínate que está justo por aquí y en
el cromosoma homólogo está justo por
aquí vamos a pensar que está justo por
aquí y recuerda que ambos son cromosomas
homólogos que codifican para los mismos
genes pero pueden tener distintas
versiones de los genes es decir los
alelos y si allende el tamaño de los
dientes no sé se me ocurre tomarlo por
aquí está justo por aquí y en el
cromosoma homólogo está justo por aquí
entonces date cuenta que si segregan
independientemente después de que ocurre
la meiosis
qué produce los gametos los chicos
pueden tener un cromosoma de este estilo
y no septal vez este otro cromosoma es
decir un gen con el color de ojos y otro
cromosoma con el gen del tamaño de los
dientes o pues al revés que tengan a
este de aquí y por otra parte agarren a
este otro cromosoma con el gen del
tamaño de los dientes podrías obtener
otra versión del alelo debido a que
están en diferentes cromosomas no están
ligados cuando los heredas si eres las
dientes grandes o dientes chicos esto no
influye en que le des ojos cafés u ojos
azules ahora bien también tenemos la
otra situación y déjame ponerlo por aquí
solamente para que lo veas la otra
situación es que estén en el mismo
cromosoma déjame notar aquí
otra característica se me ocurre color
de cabello cabello bien ahora imagínate
esto
imagínate que el gen del color del
cabello también lo tenemos en el
cromosoma 1 y lo tenemos justo por aquí
justo por aquí y justo por aquí lo voy a
poner justo así y ojo pueden ser
distintas versiones del color de cabello
distintos alelos pero los genes están en
el mismo cromosoma en esta situación si
alguien digamos tiene el alelo de los
ojos azules déjame plano aquí imagínate
que este es el alelo de los ojos azules
azules y este es el alelo del color del
cabello rubio vamos a plantas y rubio
bueno estos siempre van a viajar juntos
no sucederá que se segregan
independientemente en este caso a esto
se les llama caracteres ligados estos de
aquí serían caracteres ligados déjame
mover un poco la pantalla para ponerlo
así estos de aquí van a ser caracteres
ligados
y
2 y dejame subrayado- es muy importante
y de hecho en futuros vídeos voy a
hablar un poco sobre ellos sobre los
caracteres ligados y de hecho sobre los
caracteres ligados especialmente los
ligados al sexo probablemente los
próximos vídeos pero supongamos que
estamos estudiando características que
se segregan independientemente y que
estamos cruzando dos híbridos entonces a
esto se llama una cruza de híbrida y sé
que suena una palabra muy extravagante
pero nos va a ayudar bastante a entender
este concepto nos da la idea del poder
que tiene el cuadro de poulet y para eso
vamos a hacer lo justo por acá como ya
no tengo espacio voy a jalar justo por
acá y vamos a trabajar por aquí mi
siguiente cuadro de paulette el cual va
a ser lo siguiente
imagínate que tengo dos padres que son
híbridos híbridos para ambos alelos por
lo tanto van a ser de la forma b el
alelo de los ojos cafés
el anhelo de los ojos azules y bueno
para los dientes va a ser de mayúscula
en la ley lo para los vientos grandes y
el alelo para los dientes pequeños en
este caso ambos padres son híbridos para
estos dos genes y en este caso vamos a
decir que ambos padres ambos padres son
de híbridos de híbridos son híbridos
para ambos genes ahora cuáles son las
distintas combinaciones que pueden tener
sus hijos y bueno pude haber hecho esto
sin ti híbridos no sé como ocurre tomar
un humor cigoto para las características
de de los dientes t mayúscula t
mayúscula o gnomos y voto dominante pero
lo voy a hacer con de híbridos porque
lleva a más variedad y se estudia
seguido en las clases entonces si estoy
hablando de la mamá déjame ponerlo por
aquí si estoy hablando de la mamá
entonces cuáles son las distintas
combinaciones de genes que puede donar
la mamá bueno por cada una de las
características que tengo aquí date
cuenta que ella sólo puede donar uno de
los alelos uno de los alelos para el
color de ojos y además uno de los alelos
para el tamaño de los dientes entonces
ella puede donar este alelo café déjame
ponerlo si este alelo café y a su vez
donar este alelo de los dientes grandes
lo voy a poner así o bueno en su dado
caso puede donar también este alelo de
los ojos cafés y bueno un alelo de los
dientes pequeños lo voy a poner justo
así o bueno también en su caso puede
donar este alelo de los ojos azules y
bueno esta lelo de los dientes grandes
de los dientes grandes o puede ser
también el alelo de los ojos azules y el
alelo de los dientes pequeños puede ser
así para la mama y puede ser lo mismo
para el papá porque el papá también es
de híbrido
puede contribuir con las mismas
combinaciones entonces déjame escribirlo
podemos tener un papá que donnie steele
lo de los ojos cafés antes va a poner de
una vez todos los colores para hacerlo
más rápido está el de los ojos cafés o
puede ser también el alelo de los ojos
azules o el de los ojos azules y bueno
podemos tener a estate mayúscula para
los dientes grandes dientes pequeños
aquí va a ser el alelo de los ojos
azules y los dientes grandes y el alelo
de los ojos azules y los dientes
amarillos no no no no espera no
amarillos no de dientes pequeños ese
sería un gen distinto un gen para el
color de los dientes y bueno creo que
eso más bien se debe a factores
ambientales pero bueno hagamos nuestro
cuadro de pune y este cuadro de poulet
date cuenta que va a ser un súper cuadro
de pune porque va a tener 16
combinaciones distintas si aquí tengo
cuatro combinaciones en cada uno me va a
dar un total de 16 combinaciones
distintas
y ya está de lujo porque 4x4 es 16 y
ahora las voy a poner con un color
neutro para no estar cambiando todos los
colores así que me voy a tomar el color
blanco y vamos a fijarnos lo siguiente
en este caso puedo tener la combinación
alelo café de la mamá y alelo café del
papá en este caso es café café café café
y después tengo un estate en mayúscula y
estrategia mayúscula eso para los
dientes y bueno aquí voy a tener en
mayúscula b mayúscula d mayúscula y
minúscula en este caso voy a tener de
mayúsculas de minúsculas t mayúscula y t
mayúscula y en este caso voy a tener b
mayúscula y minúscula d mayúscula y
minúscula y bueno estamos en la primera
fila vamos a hacer la segunda fila y
para esto voy a decir aunque tengo b
mayúscula en mayúscula t mayúscula
d minúscula
y bueno espero que no sea muy cansado
para ti es más déjame mejor parar un
poco el vídeo y llenar todo esto para
que no pierdas tu tiempo así que paremos
el vídeo listo ya nos ahorramos algo de
tiempo y yo llené todo con las
combinaciones que necesitábamos justo
como lo hace en algunos programas de
cocina ahora que ya tenemos todas las
combinaciones posibles y podemos hablar
un poco acerca de los prototipos pues
vamos a ver qué se puede ver debido a
esta cruzada híbrida por ejemplo cuántos
de estos van a exhibir a ojos cafés y
dientes grandes y para eso voy a bajar
un poco más mi pantalla para notar lo
justo aquí lo que voy a buscar aquí son
ojos cafés
y dientes grandes y
dientes
usted es grande
grandes y para eso vamos a aplicarnos en
este cuadro de pune y bueno date cuenta
que esencialmente lo que estoy buscando
es que tengan una b mayúscula y una t
mayúscula porque tanto ojos cafés como
dientes grandes son dominantes así que
en este caso voy a tener uno aquí tengo
ojos cafés y dientes grandes aquí tengo
a ojos cafés y dientes grandes aquí
tengo ojos cafés y dientes grandes aquí
tengo ojos cafés y dientes grandes y
date cuenta que en este caso los ojos
cafés dominan a los ojos azules y los
dientes grandes dominan a los dientes
pequeños por lo tanto este individuo en
su fenotipo va a expresar ojos cabeza
dientes grandes ojos cafés dientes
grandes cual más ojos cafés dientes
grandes ojos cafés dientes grandes y
éste no esté date cuenta que es ojos
cafés pero los dientes son pequeños
entonces cuidado no vayas a caer en un
error pero este si ojos cafés dientes
grandes este no esté si ojos cafés
dientes grandes y estos no no no no y
éste tampoco ojos cafés dientes pequeños
si te diste cuenta estos dos fueron de
híbridos heterocigotos para las dos
características pero los ojos cafés y
los dientes grandes son dominantes por
lo que todos estos son fenotipos de ojos
cafés y dientes grandes así que si los
contamos ojos cafés y dientes grandes es
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 de ellos
ok ahora vamos a ver otro caso cuáles
son los que tienen ojos grandes
ojos cafés perdón café estamos hablando
del color de ojos y dientes dientes
pequeños
qué
bueno pues vamos a buscarlo este tiene
ojos cafés dientes pequeños
éste también ojos cafés dientes pequeños
este no esté no esté no este no pero es
decir ojos cafés dientes pequeños
entonces son 33 de ellos bien ahora qué
pasa si quiero ojos color azul y dientes
grandes bajemos un poco en la pantalla y
lo que quiero son ojos color azul lo voy
a poner con este color
color azul azul y
dientes grandes grandes bueno pues este
tiene ojos azules dientes grandes ojos
azules dientes grandes ojos azules
dientes grandes y bueno en este caso no
le faltan los dientes grandes y por lo
tanto tengo a tres de ellos y bueno pues
si quisiera el último que sería bajemos
un poco más la pantalla y vamos a ver el
último caso el último caso es tener los
ojos azules
azules y dientes pequeños dientes
pequeños
que nos
y ese caso solamente lo cumplen este de
aquí este de aquí es el que tiene ojos
azules y dientes pequeños por lo tanto
solamente es uno solo hay una
combinación de las 16 que había donde un
hijo es de edad de ambos padres los
alelos recesivos para ambas
características y bueno si ves esto te
puedes preguntar en probabilidades cuál
es la probabilidad de tener un hijo de
ojos cafés y dientes grandes bueno hay
16 combinaciones para eso dejamos subir
un poco la pantalla y las veas aquí
tengo 16 combinaciones todas estas de
aquí y de las 16 combinaciones sólo
nueve de ellas tienen esa propiedad sólo
nueve de 16 tienen ojos cafés y dientes
grandes de igual manera te puedes
preguntar ojos azules y dientes pequeños
y solamente uno de 16 tienen esas dos
características en fin ojalá que en este
vídeo hayas comprendido el poder del
cuadro de pune
como este veas la fuerza que tiene para
explorar todas las posibles
características de los genes en este
caso no solamente tenemos un gen sino
que tenemos dos características que
muestran dominancia pero que se segregan
independientemente porque están en
distintos cromosomas también los puedes
usar para ver la dominancia incompleta
que la teníamos justo por aquí donde
teníamos una combinación o una mezcla de
las características como aquí en el
ejemplo de las flores donde teníamos que
el rojo junto con el blanco me daban
flores rosas y también lo puedes ver en
las situaciones donde tenemos como
dominancia
como esta de aquí recuerdas donde tienes
múltiples alelos en este caso tenemos
tres versiones del gen y hay dos que son
co dominantes en fin espero que lo hayas
disfrutado bastante